hi YouTube my name is a Philip Jennings
on the general secretary of uni global
Union world's largest trade union the
Davos conference is about to finish in
five minutes time and I thought would be
a time to reflect on have you judge the
success of this event in terms of
working people around the world we
represent working people around the
world so I just thought as a message to
Klaus Schwab and to Tony Blair the chair
person a message to them about how they
judge the success of this year through
our eyes first of all we've witnessed
this week financially a mini financial
meltdown and a and a kind of Davos
bounce we've also had the world's
biggest banking fraud in France so
therefore first criteria financial
regulation are the people here prepared
to give financial regulators the tools
to ensure that the financial records
that we've seen this week is brought to
an end this is not business as usual
these things aren't change then we
consider this davos as being a damp
squib secondly there's been a great deal
of discussion about poverty therefore
I'd like to suggest that in one year's
time we look at the share of wages and
the wealth produced by our nation's and
then we can judge as to whether wages
have increased their share in national
wealth or not most people here have been
talking about poverty reduction let's
see if that's going to make a difference
in people's populace another big favors
in poverty reduction is to give people
to some work and jobs let's look in one
year's time and see if the number of
jobs of interest all the number of jobs
have decreased there's been a huge
discussion here about global citizenship
ie making businesses good corporate
citizens and they're going to behave
ethically and socially and so forth so
let's see if multinational companies are
prepared to sign up global agreements
with global unions like uni there are 65
in the world today I would like to think
with all the great intentions expressed
that by this time next year we will have
hundred global agreements in place with
trade unions around the world private
equity is here we've brought them out of
the shadows I'd like to see that in the
world of private equity they also begin
to pass the global citizenship test we
talked about poverty and health and
climate change let's see if carbon
emissions have actually been reduced
during the course of the next year when
it comes to the great societal questions
of ill health and under development
let's see if the leak table of
application of the Millennium
Development Goals has actually improved
born or made an appeal let's see if bo
knows appeal has actually been met
finally a target that we have in the
global union movement and all of civil
society is that this is the 60th
anniversary of the human rights
declaration we want people around the
world to stand up we want to break the
Guinness Book of Records which is 43
million people stood up last year for
their rights this year we want 45
million people to stand up for their
rights so there we have it a checklist
for Klaus a checklist for Tony Blair and
the executive board I sincerely hope we
make progress in each of these areas and
if we do I can assure you the world
would be a better place Thank You
YouTube over and out